clear indication that how desperate one
these people are and also it's an
indication for those who want to exploit
the world's most vulnerable people here
in Hungary we are seeing desperate
asylum seekers arriving every day by
thousands over 2,000 every day yesterday
we saw over 3,000 and it's the same
movement which arrives in degrees all
desperate people Syrians Iraqis of rons
and they're looking for safety and if
something like this happens it's
appalling and it shows how dysfunctional
European as Island systems are that
people won't have to give themselves up
to the sea if they survive there they
end up like this horrible yeah I mean in
truce the refrain seems to be at the
moment that Europe hasn't faced anything
in terms of the volumes of humanity who
are currently on the move since the end
of World War two so inevitably some of
those processes are incapable of coping
yes they are but also I think we want to
go back to the principal the
humanitarian principle and when we see
humans in need of protection and when
they run for their lives we agreed years
years years ago as humans that they need
to be protected how do we know how can
we test how can we be sure that the
people who say they are fleeing conflict
and our legitimate asylum seekers are
what they say they are we receive lots
of emails more viewers saying how do we
know these people could be terrorists
yes they could be criminals looking to
start a new life they may be what they
say they are yes I mean it's like
putting those people to test who have
been through so much but there is a way
you know there are mechanisms that have
been put in place that mechanism that
needs to be improved how you want to put
that question to someone who has fled
syria Homs who has fled Iraq who has
fled afghanistan have seen death with
her own eyes I'm meeting a lot of people
who are
here and the stories are that they have
seen their own relatives being killed
you know so the choice is either to stay
and die or there or come look for
Humanity is there another choice and
it's nifty is there another choice and
we think to the example provided by the
Australian Government which faces a very
different kind of humanitarian crisis
migrants trying to reach Australia which
took a very very muscular approach to
this problem they said we're not going
to let anybody else come to Australia
and they stop the boats that were coming
there and what they found was that when
people knew they couldn't get in they
stopped trying to get in Israa danger in
allowing more people to come you create
a magnet effect the more people that are
succeeding and entering Europe the more
that will try to enter Europe the
Australia is not the best example for
Europe to follow that's very clear what
they have done is they have a problem
with ports when Davis when somewhere you
try to stop the tide of refugees they're
vulnerable human beings so they are
exploited by ruthless smugglers in an
other direction what we want Europe to
do is the right thing to deal with these
people humanely with humanity and with
dignity I mean you see all these people
I mean they you have to be desperate to
give yourselves to this ruthless some
smugglers who cross the Mediterranean
and then why would you walk with your
family women children elderly for days
and days and days these are desperate
people refugees are fleeing fear
refugees are not to be feared